hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to amateur surgeon Christmas
edition now I vaguely remember trying to
play this game in the past but I don't
think I've ever actually made a video
out of it
so that's exactly what I'm going to be
doing I've never really played these
games but I can only imagine that it
functions in a similar way that surgeon
simulator does you're a surgeon by the
name of dr. Alan probe oh geez Oh Oh God
okay why did that have to happen
stupid North Pole no one told me they
had to drive on the wrong side of the
sky here hey why are the presents
everywhere does anybody here well if
that guy in the tree looks bad I wonder
if my tools are crash
dammit oh well there must be loads of
things around here that I can use okay
we're going right into it alright nice
boobs I think all right whatever so this
is amateur surgeon it's a bit quiet in
here but good thing I've put in some
Christmas music to lighten the mood and
also I'm very festive because that's
exactly how these twelve days of
Christmas are gonna go so let's get
started because I've got nothing better
to do with my time what the hell are you
doing why'd you honestly have no idea
don't worry I'm a surgeon if you get
nervous while I'm working disgust me to
pause I can tell you about injuries or
tools I'm using okay ah deal okay first
I need to extract these items I've only
got this grabber
so hold still guys seem safe sorry once
I'm done I'll save you up okay yeah so
it's just kind of like a lot of
searching games that I played kind of
like that super super uh Wii game that I
played in the pasture and soothe the
pain wait some why was that did I miss
something here wire looks like it's
attached to something in your body maybe
I can find out more of eyes Abid yeah
it's probably good idea
that sounds like a bad idea yeah I'm
kind of with you on it but I already did
something sorry I don't know what's with
the glowing lights no you have oh I know
something duct tape sorry sorry sorry
what am i damn i doing something wrong
oh okay all right I got this okay then I
burn it no no well I'm [ __ ] up
royally here I'm sorry buddy even though
you were apparently just talking to me
you're probably gonna die
can't be helped damn it tomorrow well
apparently it's discovered that I'm a
very bad doctor that likes to kill
people nurse would you kindly shut the
[ __ ] up and try to help me here instead
of being a sack of [ __ ] dies on me yeah
I [ __ ] up there but that's okay
because I wasn't really ready to do
anything I was just gonna get on my way
and try to fix his goddamn elf
oh I needed morte is that what I needed
ah it wasn't closed enough ah soothing
oh that's nice oh that's real nice I'm
doing great okay
caboose key all right does this help
that didn't [ __ ] help a goddamn thing
what is that supposed to do knife oh
okay I'm getting the hang of it now
I mean hang of this burn burn burn burn
because for some reason this is a good
idea blam blam blam bah a Lamba mylanta
all right
I'm going in wait why am I going in
nurse why am i going in oh that's not
right well that's not right at all yeah
that seems bad oh I used a drill then
trace read section away what well this
seems like a ballad well I [ __ ] up the
Helen
I've no idea one of you
[Music]
by pigeon was burned alive why was his
heart on fire and why was he able to
talk to me if it's hard was on [ __ ]
fire nurse why did you get me a magical
goddamn patient goddamnit nurse shut the
[ __ ] up nurse shut up nurse I'm a doctor
oh no come on come on live you best live
live you bastard
live you bastard god damn it damn it
damn it damn it why is it [ __ ]
impossible the patient's burned alive
then maybe there's some way to put out
the fire oh that that's amazing
Susan there's a [ __ ] guy oh oh I
didn't know that oh that's [ __ ] there's
a good oh [ __ ] see I didn't I didn't
know that
aha burns are being caused by the fire
you put the fire out by sucking up blood
and blowing it at it
I suck up this blood then I'm gonna blow
it that's so smart oh my god the fire
it's out that's [ __ ] incredible oh my
god this is so much easier than racing
the [ __ ] clock trying to do the other
[ __ ] that I was doing oh this is so
much easier alright so now I got bad and
then I fix it up with pixie dust and
then I put that there and they fix this
[ __ ] there we go okay I gotta get it in
segments before I'm able to do this [ __ ]
but this is easy cuz it's done yes this
is oh my god that's so much easier now
that I actually know what I'm supposed
to be doing
I'm spending forever on that nurse why
did you [ __ ] tell me why well now
that I know what I'm supposed to do what
the hell are you doing here some crazy
jerk on a sled pulled by a bunch a bunch
of flying dogs leap pry it out in front
of me you idiot
those are reindeer that was Santa what
are you talking about [ __ ] up hey it's
Anna uh so what do we do now
yay that [ __ ] took forever I'll try
to do one more mission mincer where's
Santa is he okay I think one of the
flying dogs got sucked into my jet
engines and he crashed you killed one of
the reindeer it might be alive it's
disturbed by the Jets
well bits of it anyway oh my god men sir
you have to save them I know what a save
bit sir mr. looks like he's seen better
days
oh boy
want to do this guess I'll just have to
piece this together as I go I guess I
will then okay how is their hard
breathing oh god oh god that's not good
oh okay is this thing gonna be alive
after I'm done I don't think I want to
know that I have these magical powers oh
boy oh boy if I don't have the right
part I'll just have to use a substitute
okay all right oh okay all right
oh boy oh boy this goes here this goes
there that goes there this goes over
here yeesh nurse you might want to look
away for this one oh this dog seen
better days
oh it's bad dear for this doggy we
missing something
hidey-hole there it is okay I got it
oh boy I don't know if I want to be a
part of this this seems like something
that's a diabolical experiment from hell
and I don't think I want I don't know
know where that goes
is it a leg oh it's like oh yeah
okay alright then let's go in oh boy oh
boy yeah you know it's a bad sign when
everything I do needs to be burned on oh
boy I don't even want to know what this
is this is PVC piping I'm using as
either artery or intestine either way
it's grotesque and I should feel bad
about it but somehow I only feel
empowered by it at least this one's
going a bit smoother than the last one
what is it what is this at a vacuum my
using a vacuum as a substitute why is it
even a living thing oh god I don't know
where this one goes
[Music]
the [ __ ] goddamn end you gonna do
that to me at the end when I'm at the
[ __ ] and after I go through all the
other [ __ ]
excuse my prepubescent voice but what
the [ __ ] dick oh it's a five as the
[ __ ] bolts in the goddamn leg oh I'm
a ninny
nurse why the [ __ ] did you let me be an
idiot I should just blame me over my
problems now I just need a conductor and
to give it some juice that's my [ __ ]
phone just going up its ass yep that
went up its ass alright let's give her
some juice I've just have to complete
the circuit
- [ __ ] Oh honk clerk oh boy he's up and
running I'd say that's pretty impressive
even if it's a bit Frankenstein oh he's
trying to tell us something what is it
boy did somebody fall down the well it
he can sense where Santa is we have to
follow him how's the elf not questioning
why this is horrible but there's
something you'll need to do first I mean
they often ask a question that this is
horrible that somehow I as a doctor I'm
able to bring a horribly mangled body to
life oh my god my voice is just [ __ ]
god that is all for amateur surgeon
Christmas edition I don't know what kind
of hellhole alternate reality this all
takes place in but it's horrible and
they should be a bad about what they're
doing here but either way I had fun hope
you did too
I hope to have my video my voice my
voice back to on 2% by next video maybe
it will maybe it won't thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]